senegal o egipto sabio manejo mohamed
salah ese es el duelo que está planteado
para la gran final de la copa africana
de naciones en el estadio del mbe que
pondrá fin a la edición número 33 del
torneo se asoma con un partido cerrado
de pronóstico incierto entre dos de los
equipos más regulares del certamen no
siempre lucen no siempre juegan bien
pero son equipos que se han mostrado
regulares y que han tenido solidez es
defensiva e individualidades como para
definir los partidos del lado de senegal
el panorama es un poco más amable porque
no cuenta con bajas para disputar este
encuentro a liu si se es el
seleccionador y ha sido protagonista de
las dos finales perdidas del conjunto
senegalés en 2012 como jugador y en 2019
como entrenador así que buscará también
saldar una deuda personal y una deuda
que mantiene este equipo senegalés con
sus aficionados del lado de egipto el
panorama es un poco más complicado
porque viene acumulando bajas a lo largo
del torneo a las del arquero a mohamed
el shenawi del defensor ahmed hegazi por
mencionar algunos se sumó para esta
final la suspensión de omar kamal y
también la de sus seleccionadores
es carlos quiroz a quien no podrá estar
en el banquillo de igual manera egipto
se encomienda a un espíritu combativo
histórico y esa supremacía que ha
mostrado a esa mentalidad que ha
mostrado para ejercer esa supremacía en
el fútbol africano el que lo lleva a ser
el equipo más ganador del torneo con
siete trofeos sea para quien sean al
final será un momento histórico o la
primera corona para senegal o la octava
para egipto que de esa manera ampliaría
su récord como máximo monarca del fútbol
africano